Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to The David
Pakman Show. Luke Beasley here filling in for
David today while he is away. I don't waste
any time, so let's just jump right in. Donald
Trump spoke over the weekend at the Faith and
Freedom Coalition event in Nashville, Tennessee.
This is one of his first chances, actually
his first chance in speech form at least,
to address the bombshells that have been revealed
in the three January six hearings that have
happened so far. And it was also a chance for
him to do what he normally does in speeches,
which is go through his greatest hits of talking
points and then kind of get on random tangents
about random things. So we're gonna be looking
at some of the moments from that speech today,
starting with Trump saying that no teacher should
be teaching students transgender. What that means,
I don't know. Not about transgender people.
Not any way you could say that properly about
transgender singular. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Pushing woke gender ideology.
Woke gender ideology. Think of it on young
people is nothing less than child abuse.
No teacher should ever be allowed
to teach transgender to our children
without the parents consent. And I don't think too
many people are going to be giving that consent.
Speaker 1: But not too many men. We we got
to keep those teachers from teaching about
transgender. Wow. Of course, he's playing into
the right's favorite fear mongering device
as of late, which is the LGBTQ community
doing everything they can to make their
followers distracted from anything except
being afraid of people who are not like them.
Then Trump moved on to speaking about the public
January six hearings and went on this tangent
about how great of a nickname the UN Select
Committee is what he calls it. It's the Select
Committee investigating January six, but he calls
it the UN Select Committee and he was very proud
of coming up with this nickname. And
I was actually watching his speech
on my own livestream, which you can subscribe
to my channel I Luke Beasley on YouTube.
If you're watching this on YouTube or listening to
podcasts, there will be a link in the description.
You just click it, go to my channel, subscribe,
or if you listen to podcasts. I also put it out
in audio form so you can search my name on any
podcast listening platform. But I was watching
his speech on a livestream and he got into this
tangent about, Oh, the UN Select Committee,
isn't that such a great nickname? And for
some reason that just tickled me so much.
So I had to include it. Here is that it's.
Speaker 2: Being staged by the UN Select
Committee. I love that name. And so, you know,
they never they actually, you know, they hate it,
right. But they act like there's nothing wrong
because they just don't want the very good at
what they do. They're kind people, they're con
artists. I say the UN select you're supposed to
be the select committee on January. You
know, like these people are legitimate
the UN selects so I call them the UN selects
and they act like, oh, they never mention it. I
think it's one of the great, they never mention
it. Someday they give me credit for that term.
I had a lot of good times. They had a lot of good
nicknames. Didn't me? Didn't we have great victims
I think is one of the best. I
don't know. It's not catching
on because they won't let it catch on.
Speaker 1: Just a genius of of comedy and
of burns, man. I can't even I can't even take it.
And then he moved on to talking about how calm
of a speech January 6th was. He said it possibly
was his calmest speech that he's ever given. Wow.
Can you believe it?
Speaker 2: It's to various speeches, including
one I gave. Remember the com words I used. They
try and make them sound like that was a calm. That
might have been the calmer speech I think I've
ever made, if you want to know. I've had a couple
of senators say I never knew you could be so nice.
Speaker 1: Next, he points out that for some
reason, the January six hearings aren't focused
on the election. Lies that I've been telling. Of
course, in his mind, they're not focusing on the
massive fraud or he called it the stuff we want
to hear. They're not focusing on the stuff we want
to hear. Let's go ahead and take a look at that.
Speaker 2: Crooked it was. Meanwhile,
the committee refuses to play
any of the tape of people saying the good
things, the things that we want to hear.
It's a one way street. It's a rigged deal.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine? The January six
hearing is not spending time focusing on the
lies that caused the event that the January six
hearing is even looking into wild. Finally, he
decides to go ahead and talk about Mike Pence.
And in that, he denies that he called Mike
Pence a wimp, which is one of the things
that came out of these hearings was people
saying they remembered him taking this really
harsh tone against Mike Pence and calling him
a wimp, as well as other things. But apparently
that didn't happen, according to Trump.
Speaker 2: One guy got up and said that
he heard me calling Mike Pence. So now, in all
honesty, I'm the president of the United States.
You know, I'm sitting I think they said of like
he's a wimp. How many people listen to me? It's
like I don't even know who these people are.
But I never called Mike Pence a wimp. I never
called him a wimp. Mike Pence had a chance to be
great. He had a chance to be, frankly, historic.
But just like Bill Barr and the rest of these weak
people, Mike and I say it sadly because I like
them, but Mike did not have the courage to act.
Speaker 1: So there you go. Nothing too
surprising from him in his response, going on
with the same lies about the 2020 election,
pretending that Pence should have stepped
in the way of our constitutional process.
And he's just further increasing the likelihood
that they will attempt to do this again and maybe
it will be successful next time. And that's what
really scares me. All the evidence that has come
out during these hearings hasn't made him stop for
one moment to think, maybe I should go ahead and
move on from this. And obviously, I didn't think
he was going to come out and become this defender
of democracy and, you know, revoke all the things
he said before. No, but I at least hoped it would
be so embarrassing, the hard evidence that was
presented in these hearings, which I think they've
done a good job of doing. But I was hoping that
would at least get him to go. I'm going to back
off of this a little bit, even if I'm not going to
ever. Change what I believe or change what I say
publicly. I'm going to stop talking about it so
much. But no, his only response to all of this is
to keep telling the lies that got it got us into
this mess. And that is very, very frightening.